guten tag ja ich habe ben & jerry's da
ich bin eure mal wanne und willkommen zu
einem neuen look bank heute am
montagabend ihr seht es nicht am
montagabend ihr seht das an irgendeinem
anderen tag ja und ich hab mir heute
überlegt zum fernsehabend was kein
fernseher abends ist es ist ein eis
essen abend traurig alleine auf der
couch ich habe überlegt worüber ich
heute in diesem buch beim sprechen
möchte und dann dachte ich dass es
reicht mal ganz cool wäre kommentare zu
beantworten während ich weiß es und
vielleicht am besten die kommentare aus
dem nächsten coup an
ich lese eigentlich fast jedes kommentar
aber beantworte halt nicht alle
also lasst uns loslegen buch welches ben
& jerry's habe ich natürlich peanut
butter cup denn peanut butter cups ist
das beste wenn und service als zu man
haben kann
ich habe auch noch chips gekauft und
einen gemütlichen abend also kommentare
kommentieren die handy hülle
ja dies neu schön dass es euch
aufgefallen ist natürlich darf mein
lover bild nicht fehlen ich feiere das
so wie viele leute von euch das gut
finden und kommentieren das in dieses
lama bild oder alpaka ist ein alpaka
alpaka welt haben wollen ich verlege
unten woher das ist auch wenn diese
leute mich nicht geantwortet haben ich
habe nämlich auf dieser seite
[Musik]
ben & jerry's das allerbeste eis der
welt
halle berrys falls ihr das seht ihr
könnt mich gerne etwas eis zu schicken
wenn das nicht so schön teuer werden
auch öfter holen
sie habe auf dieser seite wo das
altarbild auch hier ist eine garderobe
garderobe also kleider aufhängen und und
ein paar schuhe einpacken
für 500 euro gesehen
aber ich habe mich so in diese garderobe
beliebt dass ich die halle war und
dachte so wollen bin ich gerade rosig
sagt man dass sie auch von euch ist aber
die haben sich nie gemeldet
nach dieser hotel story mit dem
influenza kann ich mir auch schon
vorstellen warum also es schon kommen
wahrscheinlich das ganze in florenz
allerdings mittlerweile habe ich das
auch ist mir das eigentlich so ganz
geheuer als ich habe heute von einer
armbanduhren hersteller ist alle welche
nicht meine denke ich mal eine mail
bekommen und jetzt passt auch leute ihr
werdet ausrasten ich habe eine mail
bekommen dass ich ein geschenkset also
eine uhr mit dem anderem armband bekomme
und dafür drei instagram post mache und
drei stories ich habe diese dieser
amateur hersteller das ist jetzt nicht
so besitzt ein start-up willst du nicht
vielleicht unsere ur promoten nee das
ist so ein richtiger luxus armbanduhren
hersteller alles mal ganz ehrlich ja
also schöne uhr geschenk zu kriegen
aber ich nervt auch meine community
nicht drei tage mit drei bildern von
dieser uhr und bekomme dafür dann nur
die uhr
wenn ich produktplatzierung mache oder
werbung auf instagram
dann überlegen wir schon ganz genau
lohnt es sich mit sachen zu stressen für
das was ich machen möchte deswegen mache
ich halt auch so selten weil ich halt da
richtig aussortieren was wo hinter ich
zum beispiel komplett selber stehe was
ich gut finde was ich noch so auf
instagram vertreten lässt
und es lässt sich nicht vertreten drei
bilder von der uhr zu schicken
zu den kosten für eine uhr also
dankeschön nein das war so lustig genau
weil dann noch zu diesen drei hinter
campos hätte ich noch ein rabatt code
einen persönlichen rabatt bekommen mit
dem ihr dann 15 prozent oder 10
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher aber so
der ein paar prozent bekommt auch seine
überteuerte uhr zu kaufen
ich darf nicht super jetzt wohl noch
anfangen abnehmen ttc zum abnehmen euch
an zu drehen und dann läuft's und falls
sie mir noch nicht auf instagram
fachleute weiter dass hier gerade seht
euch aufhält ich folge x beine noch gar
nicht auf instagram dann ändert dies
jetzt schnell denn ich poste auch sehr
lustige stories und das verpasst ihr
wenn ihr nicht auf instagram folgt es
sei denn er hat keine instagram dann ist
es okay dann müssten jedoch nicht
fürchten
und ben jerry's ist man nun mit einem
großen löffel kommen jetzt mit dem
kleinen löffel wo es könnte sein dass
ich heute ganz schön viel schmerz man
muss auch echt aufpassen denn ich hab
mir so im ganzen becher ich liege dann
mit bauschmerzen im bett aber ich würde
ihn schaffen das auch lustig dass ich
meinem letzten buch banken darüber
gesprochen habe dass mir nagel set
gekauft habe und heute schon 15 neue
regel haben also ihr habt wahrscheinlich
mein nagel video schon gesehen wo ich
mir die nähe gemacht habe ich habe es
mir jetzt noch mal rot gemacht und mit
so ein bisschen die sein
ich werde demnächst mal noch mal anders
machen ich bin noch ein bruder anfänger
aber ich hab auch vieles falsch gemacht
also man sollte sich doch immer
tutorials durchlesen anleitung wie man
etwas macht und nicht mehr denken dass
man das kann weil man das irgendwo mal
kurz zu behindern
kommen wir zu den kommentaren ich merke
richtig happy bin weil ich so ein
eisbecher für mich alleine
sonst wird man sich das auch eigentlich
hab ich mir mal solche sprechen mit
freunden zusammen geholt wenn man so
einen abend werden den abend oder so
gemacht hat also ihr seid herzlich
eingeladen euch einzuholen dass wir
zusammen eis essen können und wenn wir
allein ein haft sind die kernaspekte
über 1000 kommentare was kann man denn
so mutmach kommentieren
doch mal dies koch mal gas besser kannst
du nicht dass das kochen eine ganz
wichtige frage habe hier zum anfang hast
du wirklich carey kesha benutzt oder
stand er in diesem jahr beim letzten
mode bank beim raclette essen habe ich
wirklich curry ketchup benutzt ich liebe
curry ketchup ich bin mit curry ketchup
aufgewachsen ich mache auch ganz viele
essen curry ketchup
danach schmeckt das essen immer gleich
aber es ist dieser curry ketchup
geschmack okay jetzt weiß ich warum
darunter so viele kommentare sind weil
das alles wie schmeckt vorschläge sind
es ist so verrückt nervigen dieses
format dann haben wir auch so spaß vor
allem beim schneiden wenn man dann immer
noch so films sehen oder sehen auch sehr
gut aussehen muss und dass dann so
zusammen schneidet jetzt bei den küss
den frosch weiß ich wer das macht total
spaß
die kommentare unter beim letzten muck
bahn sind jetzt ja ich sag mal ja
dschungelcamp lasst uns bitte über das
dschungelcamp werden leute oh mein gott
effektives ganz ehrlich ohne twitter
würde ich gar nichts davon mitbekommen
dass überhaupt wieder dschungelcamps ist
fernsehen ist so gut also
ich habe das letzte mal den fernseher
angemacht zur weihnachtszeit als ich bei
der familie war und zum einschlafen bei
der beste tipp falls sie nicht
einschlafen könnt macht qvc an
ich sag euch das funktioniert immer qvc
ist einfach die beste schlaftablette die
es gibt ja dieses trikot jetzt diese
ochsenknecht mama da ist ganz ehrlich
ich habe mir ganz kurz anguckt werden
dieses jahr dabei ist und als ich diese
ochsenknecht mal gesagt ich selber habe
an die dann nicht schon weil irgendwie
sind diese blonden älteren frauen
ich weiß nicht ob das gefühl die wollen
jedes mal ein muster aus wir brauchen
eine blonde alte und braucht mindestens
einen farbigen damit die sehen dass wir
so total so gemischt sind wir brauchen
ein jungen popstar wie heißt der
lombardi nicht die sowieso für dsds
wieso herz mein nachbar ausgeguckt da
war ich kurz schockiert weil ich mir von
meinem nachbarn erwartet
ich schaue kein bachelor und diesen
ganzen anderen kram irgendwie geht das
alles an mir vorbei ich glaube ich hätte
so viel im internet herum wenn ich mich
halt damit auf die couch legen dann
schaue ich netflix oder youtube als ich
habe so im fernsehen wo man halt auch
dieses smardtv machen kann und ja ich
bin während der wechsel youtube oder mal
auf amazon gucke ich mal was wirst du
auch für filme sind
ich habe das gefühl dass ich die filme
auf netflix durch habe
die wechseln so langsam ihre filme und
die filme die sie haben die sind ja auch
immer nicht für immer darauf die
wechseln ja immer durch und es kotzt
mich so an weil manchmal denke ich so
diesem film geschafft das habe ich schon
mal gesehen oder will ich in seeth und
dann ist ja noch nicht mehr drauf ja das
ist ihr beruf wehren sind gucken
mein gott ich bin so individuell kein
fernsehen
ich muss zu meiner verteidigung auch
sagen es ist jetzt halb elf montag
ich habe den tag über gearbeitet traurig
gemacht und ich fahre ich kann doch
immer irgendwas lagern kann ich euch
vielleicht mensch leute ich zeige euch
einfach mein einkauf ich habe nämlich
bei amazon bestellt also bei esprit und
da kann man halt auf lebensmittel
bestellt und eigentlich wie ich es nicht
machen weil amazon aber es ist halt
super praktisch weil manchmal sitze ich
dann halt nur um 18 uhr zu hause nicht
mehr so ja jetzt brauche ich noch wasser
und kartoffeln für morgen und dann
könnte ich haltlos und was an kartoffeln
schleppen oder ich drück halt einen
knopf und dann kam was an kartoffeln
einfach an wartet manchmal ein kauf
oh mein gott leute dass ich in meinem
leben mal ein heim mache ich im modus
als aber wegpacken ich habe die hälfte
geschafft nicht voll okay leute was habe
ich mir besteht
ich habe was er bestellt der in wasser
ist die quelle des lebens war gestern
das niemals das ist richtiger hole ich
habe direction sind silber geholt wenn
ich mir die spitzen blondieren möchte
also das untere und dann möchte ich
selber drauf machen für mich so unten so
hanusch skizzen hat und mit direction
silva funktioniert das super ich habe da
jetzt schon immer genutzt ich habe immer
gute erfahrungen damit gemacht während
meiner zeit sowieso
deswegen hab ich direkt ins gold dass
man das auch bei amazon kaufen kann dann
ganz wichtig bio-eier wenn man kann
wirklich viel dazu sagen also ich kaufe
bio-eier weil die steuer sind aber auch
bei bio eier die besten eier sind also
du hast ja dann noch freilandhaltung
bodenhaltung und das ist ökologisches
erzeugnis und da kann man sich schon
bisher in sicherer sein dass die hühner
case leben hatten
es ist niemals gut aber was ich sagen
will ich tausendmal die teuersten eier
die sehe da haben wir schlecht wenigsten
schlechte gewissen
so gibt sogar seine marke bei lese sie
setzten sich gegen das ermorden von
männlichen liegestühlen oder was ein wow
aber man kann halt mit ein bisschen mehr
geld kann man halt in die bessere
richtung schießen erdnuss locken
also etwas glück
xxl die wollte meine mama als kind nie
kaufen also als ich ein kind war die b 4
und meine allerliebsten lieblings chips
auf der welt ganz simple container chips
nur mit seit gewürzt ich hasse es wenn
totilas chips diesen käse pulver zeugs
draufhaben war künstlich lese geschmack
geht gar nicht und dann gab es noch eine
marke für lieber nässe eisbergsalat
superwichtig hat absolut keine nährwerte
also wirklich eisbergsalat ist
eigentlich nur wasser aber ich mag die
konsistenz und geschmack davon wenn ich
mir ein brot schmieren back ich mir
gerne mal als bett an hart drauf und
weintrauben anlocken ist von weintrauben
und eine bio gurke und ich ganz ehrlich
ich verstehe das nicht mit diesem
bio-gurken die normalen nicht bio gurken
haben kein plastik drum und bio gucken
schwung
aber bio gurken die ist natürlich nicht
bio weil klassik und so aber wenn man
schon ein bio produkt hat warum macht
man es dann kaputt indem man klassik
drum wickelt und da gibts bestimmt jetzt
ein in den kommentaren der die antwort
kennt sagt hermann ist aber ganz logisch
weil bio gurken
bitte beantworten diese ganz
komplizierte frage ich wusste gar nicht
dass ein paket von julien
dabei ist mir entstanden julian bär gut
leute dazu hast
ich werde meine kartoffeln jimmy carter
doch unvergessen
na super jedoch so wieder selber
einkaufen richtig kindergeburtstag
feeling erdnussflips und eiscreme
ok wieder mal ein bisschen seltsames
video aber an sich in school oder wir
sehen uns einfach das nächste mal wieder
bei einem video und versetzen dies mache
das nächste video wird lustig habe mir
schon sehr gespannt darauf ist drehe ich
übermorgen beim morgen muss ich zu plan
und los ich bin eine wichtige
moderatorin mit einem richtigen job